mais c'est vrai est notre invité
politique ce matin c'est sébastien chenu
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
un porte parole du rassemblement
national tant parole de la candidate
marine le pen on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et de
ouest-france grosstephan bonjour bonjour
et sébastien chenu on va bien sûr parler
du programme de marine le pen de sa
campagne mais d'abord l'actualité cette
nuit c'est cette grande offensive qui a
été lancé par les russes dans l'est de
l'ukraine dont la redoute et offensif
pour prendre le dombass marine le pen
l'a immédiatement condamné en cette
offensive comment on peut imposer la
tête à vladimir poutine aujourd'hui par
la diplomatie c'est le seul chemin c'est
le seul chemin viable c'est faire en
sorte que non seulement les pays
concernés mais également tous ceux qui
sont autour tout ce qu'ils peuvent aussi
avoir de l' influence sur la rue s'ils
réussissent à mener la russie à une
table des négociations
écoutez je pense qu'il ya à travers
effectivement dépression mais aussi à
travers des discussions je pense que la
russie ne vit pas en vase clos et que
son intérêt au bout du compte ce sera
aussi de cette guerre cesse là aussi
peut pas s'enfermer dans une guerre
comme celle ci de toute façon si c'est
pas la diplomatie c'est la guerre n'est
pas d'autre solution que la diplomatie
et on l'a vu dans tous les grands
conflits du monde il faudra un moment
que la russie accepte de se mettre à
cette table des négociations je crois
que la france porte cette voie en tous
les cas et nous nous comptons pas
évidemment parasiter l'action
diplomatique de la france vont continuer
à négocier continuer à parler marine le
pen avait évoqué la possibilité d'un
rapprochement avec vladimir poutine une
fois la paix conclu entre la russie et
l'ukraine est-ce qu'on peut même une
fois la guerre terminée continuer à
discuter avec la dirm protein après ce
qui s'est passé souhaitons que vladimir
poutine passe la main à un moment à des
dirigeants qui soit probablement plus
acceptable en de relation mais ce qu'il
faut c'est surtout parlé avec la russie
après on s'est réconciliés dans notre
vie avec des pays avec lesquels nous
avons été en guerre avec lesquels les
souffrances ont été très fortes on s'est
réconciliés et heureusement avec
l'allemagne notre voisin il faudra un
moment se réconcilier trouver les
chemins du dialogue avec la russie avec
vladimir poutine souhaitons que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre mais pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas encore la capacité de
décider qui va gouverner la russie après
je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que la russie
soit gouverné après par un gentil
démocrate moins gentil républicain et
pourtant il faudra parler avec eux ou
alors ça veut dire qu'on accepte tout
simplement que la russie se tourne
définitivement vers la chine et je pense
que c'est accepter des dangers que de
laisser cela moi je pense qu' il faudra
de toute façon reparler après la
signature de la paix avec la russie avec
ses dirigeants souhaitons que ce ne soit
pas la lumière poutine bien entendu très
m'as parlé de la campagne et du
programme de marine le pen et vous
l'avez sûrement entendu évidemment c'est
qu'un emmanuel macron qui a vivement
attaqué marine le pen sur la question de
l'écologie
incompétente climato sceptiques
je comprends pas pourquoi emmanuel
macron hystérise le débat en insultant
ses adversaires je dirais même accro il
a un bilan tout le monde l'a vu la
france a été condamnée pour inaction
climatique sous son quinquennat il a une
logique
car il était déjà d'ailleurs avant au
gouvernement donc il a une logique qui
est libérale et moi je pense que c'est
cette logique ultralibérale qui amène du
réchauffement climatique par exemple
donc je pense que ces deux logiques très
différentes et même à chronologique
libéral productiviste et aujourd'hui ils
rejettent sur les autres la faute moi je
crois que son bilan ne parle pas pour
lui il nous a démontré que son bilan
était très faible en matière de climat
d'ailleurs dénoncé la france a été
dénoncé d'ailleurs aussi par les
associations les organisations
écologiques donc ce n'est pas la peine
d'insulter les autres ya deux logiques
différentes monnaies logique qui est
celle du lot alice mme produire au plus
près de l'endroit où on consomme celles
des circuits courts celle de l'économie
circulaire celle du nucléaire celle de
l'hydrogène ça c'est tout ce qu'on
développe c'est tous les ans vous parler
du nucléaire les énergies renouvelables
on a l'impression que ce n'est pas votre
priorité il ya d'ailleurs pas de
financement tout cas des financements -
dans votre programme pour les énergies
renouvelables est-ce que vous allez
détruire les 9000 éoliennes existantes
alors plusieurs choses à bord le giec ne
condamne pas le nucléaire et reconnaît
la part nécessaire du nucléaire dans
l'écologie ça c'est la première chose en
ce qui concerne
c'est 100% moncler noms dont nous avons
dit que nous avions un grand projet
notamment d'investissements sur
l'hydrogène c'est qu'il ya des
puissances comme la chine qui ont
investi des milliards à l'heure où la
france d'investis que très peu sur
l'hydrogène moi je les ai vus pendant
cinq ans dans les budgets qui ont été
votées au parlement l'investissement sur
l'hydrogène il est ridicule et bien
c'est cet investissement qu'on souhaite
développer et puis sur les éoliennes
enfants si vous êtes d'accord avec
manuel mâcon oui bien sûr qu'il a rien
fait c'est toujours pareil on est là qu
on finit par être d'accord avec tout le
monde pendant la campagne électorale
sont qu'il a rien fait pendant cinq ans
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est d'abord
arrêter tout subventionnement à l'éolien
ça coûte cher c'est une énergie
intermittente et cher c'est à dire que
je vous rappelle qu'en l'éolien du tour
de pas ont fait appel aux énergies
polluantes pour prendre le relais donc
ce n'est même pas très efficace c'est
très destructeur de paysages y compris
de fonds marins très destructeur
d'emplois puisque je vous rappelle que
les pêcheurs par exemple de la baie de
somme de dieppe et c'est en tout cas la
seine maritime peuvent s'inquiéter
légitimement de voir des éoliennes
deschamps d'éolien offshore s'implanter
et puis c'est très laid s'abîme aussi
nos paysages c'est pas anecdotique de
dire c'est très laid c'est le visage de
la france qui change donc nous on arrête
de les subventionner mais celle qui
puisse qu'on a de les subventionner on
fait d'ailleurs des économies c'est de
l'argent qui ne sort pas celles qui
existent lorsqu'elle arrive à terme nous
demandons c'est là on change les règles
du jeu nous demandons aux entreprises
qui les ont implanté et bien de les
démonter de ne pas laisser les maires
moi j'ai rencontré des tas de mer petite
commune avec leurs zones yens au bout de
10 ans à devoir être démontée à leurs
propres frais c'est lors il faut changer
des règles n'est donc c'est pas dans
l'immédiat vous démontez pas les
éoliennes c'est une fois qu'elle arrive
à terme live vous savez la durée de vie
d'une éolienne c'est pas énorme c'est à
peu près une dizaine d'années et
lorsqu'elles restent sur des terrains de
petites communes etc et qu'elle laisse
ses petites communes dont les budgets
sont restreints elle leur laisse à la
charge le démontage de celle ci c'est
très problématique ça veut dire que le
coup c'est à la charge des entreprises
parce que c'est pas rien le coût des
sûretés des oriels non ces chats sont
recensés et ont changé les règles du jeu
juste pour terminer dans ce registre
vous dites changer les règles du jeu est
ce que ça veut dire que vous resterez
dans l'accord de paris si vous étiez ou
ivoire et vous est-ce que vous modifier
quoi que ce soit et notamment sur la
tenue du calendrier est ce que vous les
relations restent dans l'accord de paris
pourra regarder si le cas l'an dernier
spectable pour la france on va le
regarder ben écoute et sincèrement il
faut il faut regarder c'est en tout
point il est et peut-être des pendants
lesquelles il ne l'est pas mais
peut-être des points dans lequel il faut
accélérer moi je suis pas persuadé que
par exemple on parle et d'hydrogène tout
à l'heure je pense qu'il faut accélérer
oui je suis pas le seul dans l'accord de
paris on parle de l'hydrogène à ce point
donc je vous le redis même aux
responsabilités se voir rien entamé des
non pas des négociations et des
dialogues sur le rythme il faut que ce
soit aux tables et d'ailleurs j'ajoute
que la fée une manière d'en sortir non
non pas du tout là maintenant je vous
dis on n'en sort pas les objectifs sont
là mais la france
élèves mais attendez on peut regarder
les choses et puis pourquoi on change on
peut changer le rythme d'un calendrier
parce que aussi impacté par la crise que
nous connaissons peut-être que ce risque
n'est pas tenable pourquoi s'enfermer
dans un calendrier ci n'est pas tenable
alors qu'il ya une crise économique qui
frappe à la porte ou en tous les cas une
crise de pouvoir d'achat très importante
voilà on ne sort pas d'accord de paris
on n'en change pas les objectifs on peut
peut-être en changer le cadencement
selon ce que nous vivons ici aujourd'hui
autre sujet sur lequel marine le pen
semble avoir évolué pour ne pas dire
reculé ces derniers jours c'est
l'interdiction du voile
dans l'espace public est-ce que c'est
marine le pen est élue vous interdirait
le voile dans tout l'espace public
durant votre quinquennat bon vous savez
c'est pas c'est pas un quiz nous on a un
objectif je pense qu'il faut toujours
rappeler les objectifs l'objectif c'est
lutter éradiquer l'islamisme en france
et pour ça on a besoin de tout le monde
et en premier lieu probablement nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane
éradiquer l'islam isme ça passe d'abord
par quoi fermer les mosquées radicaliser
interdire le salafisme qui est une
idéologie on a déjà interdit d idéologie
dans notre pays étant mieux arrêter le
subventionnement de financement de
structures qui ont un lien avec
l'islamisme l'islam radical une fois
qu'on a fait ça vient la question du
voile qui va se poser parce que moi je
crois que la loi est nécessaire
la loi pour l'interdiction du voile elle
est nécessaire d'abord pour libérer les
femmes qui s'en trouve qu'ils se
trouvent enfermés
obligatoirement
par des pressions familiales
communautaire affective de ce voile qui
est aujourd'hui un symbole de
l'islamisme il ya quelques années
c'était pas le cas aujourd'hui on sait
bien que le voile est brandie par
certaines comme un symbole de
l'islamisme donc il faudra une loi pour
interdire le voile évidemment mais
comment elle va passer cette loi puisque
interdire le voile dans tout l'espace
public c'est quand même contraire à la
liberté religieuse non vous savez ça
c'est démentiel rôle du parlement c'est
le boulot du parlement si on a fait des
lois en france qui ont été amenés à
contrôler des gens pour savoir s'ils
sortaient à 5 km de chez eux au mondue
que vides on a fait des lois sur la
ceinture en dix ans ce sera jamais
appliqué jamais applicables moi je crois
je veux dire au bout d'un moment qu'à
partir de moules ya une loi le voile va
finir par tomber à partir du monde à
éradiquer l'islamisme dans notre pays
donc là je dis nous en remet au
parlement sur cette question du voile
ornements sera au donnera j'espère une
majorité à marine le pen le boulot à
l'aller
les nantais mind pour l'instant ce sera
en tous les cas au parlement de
construire la loi dans ce cas-là
d'applicable mais je crois qu'il faut
aller vers cette éradication du voile
islamique du hidjab en réalité il est là
le symbole c'est le hidjab dans la
société que nous souhaitons éradiquer
donc ça sera une loi qui sera présenté
quand est ce que c'est une priorité est
ce que ça dit d'abord vous savez d'abord
il ya le référendum sur l'immigration
qu'on veut faire passer on a un
calendrier et les français peuvent
prendre connaissance de ce calendrier
facilement puisque l'idée dans la
profession de foi de marine le pen qui
est livré dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres là où des élections
présidentielles on a d'abord un
calendrier le référendum sur
l'immigration savoir qui entre qui se
maintient qui sorte qu'ils acquièrent la
nationalité à venir mais juste dans la
loi ça sera l'interdiction pour tous les
musulmans parce qu'on a entendu marine
le pen s'adressait à une grand-mère ce
week-end et dire mais non vous c'est pas
pareil vous fait mal vous sortez
interdire le voile islamique
donc le parlement définira quelles sont
les représentations physique de
l'islamisme vous savez on a dans la loi
une définition très précise de ce que
sont les représentations physique de
certaines idéologies qui sont interdites
sur la représentation physique vous
suffit de prendre la loi c'est le hidjab
le diable c'est d'ailleurs exactement ce
qu'ils revendiquaient par les islamistes
si vous êtes en train de vous dire qu'en
fait ce serait pas une interdiction du
voile au sens strict au voile islamique
du hidjab et donc de celle ci dans
l'ensemble de l'espace public
l'interdiction de vie jaabri d'accord la
question c'est la priorité nationale
alors la priorité nationale c'est un des
points qui fait partie du fameux projet
de loi sur l'immigration que vous allez
vous souhaitez mettre en place dès
l'instauration enfin de l'arrivée au
pouvoir via référendum
ce projet de loi il touche a énormément
de points de la constitution il ya de
nouveaux articles un certain nombre
d'articles qui sont retouchées il est
très large est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que ce cet ensemble là puissent
passer le filtre du conseil
constitutionnel notamment oui tout à
fait d'ailleurs si on ne pensait pas
nous n'aurions pas travailler et
proposer ce référent même situation
analyse qui disent le contraire et
d'autres disent le contraire j'ai vu des
constitutionnalistes de très bonne aloi
de très bon niveau à dire
qu'effectivement avec l'article 11 et
pintades vous voulez faire c'est
vraiment une réussite sur dans la
constitution annoncent pas une
réécriture de la constitution vous
ajoutez des articles il ya je crois en
20 ans de mémoire je peux pas dire de
bêtises 5
retouche de la constitution mais ce
n'est pas une rue de méchant on est
d'accord c'est une modification de la
constitution montréal dans le cadre de
la 5ème république et de notre
constitution
l'association une profonde notamment sur
la priorité nationale alors allez plus
de préférence nationale mais de priorité
nationale comment est ce que vous allez
mettre cette chose-là en oeuvre la
priorité nationale ce n'est pas
l'exclusivité ça veut dire tout
simplement qu'en termes d'emploi ou de
logement je prends ces deux associés le
quotidien des français lorsqu'il ya une
possibilité une offre d'emploi une offre
de logements et bien prioritairement les
citoyens nationaux et y ont accès ça
n'exclut pas les autres ça veut dire que
prioritairement et je vous dire sur le
logement pas la façon dont le texte est
rédigé cette expression au futur
gouvernement pour décider quels sont les
emplois dont les étrangers pour aider
mes médecins ça existe déjà mais qu'est
ce que vous faites avec les binationaux
par exemple nous ne touche pas la
binationalité donc sont ils sont pas
concernés je dirige ont le même
accédants commerçants de quel côté
social donc ils sont avait dit sun non
il n'y a pas de problème des binationaux
puisque tu as dans le texte agréé
discrimination voyez aussi décidé de
priver les bises à sion ce n'est pas le
cas monsieur les aucun problème avec les
binationaux et je vous dis simplement
tout ça existe déjà par exemple la
priorité nationale on le sait elle
existe dans la fonction publique pour
les emplois mais par exemple une
priorité nationale tout bête qu'on
connaît tous c'est le droit de vote
c'est une priorité nationale et vous
regarderez le droit de vote notamment
aux élections européennes il est ouvert
aux citoyens européens
donc vous voyez il ya des choses qui
déjà dans notre cerveau nitouche riez
pas bien sûr que non mais ça veut dire
que la priorité nationale elle concerne
que les français par exemple les sites
vous fait pas de distinction entre les
j'ai les citoyens communautaires non
mais elles concernent les français la
priorité nationale par dumont vous êtes
ou français ou franco marocain franco
espagnol franco grecque vous êtes
concerné par cette priorité nationale
c'est à dire que l'on parle d'une
logique qui est très simple logique qui
existe d'ailleurs par exemple au canada
ou en suisse qui ne sont pas des
dictatures qui sont de grandes
démocraties eh bien on parle du priorité
d'une
d'une logique simple quand vous êtes
nationale citoyens de la nation
française vous avez plus de droits que
lorsque vous ne l'êtes pas et faire
passer le droit français donc en
modifiant la constitution au dessus d'un
second nous traités internationaux déjà
ratifiée par la france est-ce que
defacto c'est pas une façon de les
remettre en cause et de sons of anarchy
deux choses manière unilatérale qui nous
dit à l'union européenne rien ne
l'interdît non évidemment regarder ça
avec attention et même l'allemagne
l'allemagne a une constitution elle
aussi d'ailleurs une cour
constitutionnelle qui indique un texte
de étrangers européens tous les canons
nationale n'a pas à s'imposer à la
constitution allemande donc on s'est dit
que ce qui marchait pour l'allemagne je
vais peut-être pourrait peut-être marché
pour la france mais c'est que dans votre
programme alors il n'y a plus du tout la
sortie de l'union européenne mais on a
l'impression que mesure par mesure de
facto ça amènerait la france à sortir de
l'union européenne que vous
affranchissez de pas mal de règles de
l'union européenne quand même non
simplement on demande qu'elle bénéficie
davantage à la france je vous sais je
regardais il ya eu cinq états membres
qui ont bénéficié par exemple d'un
rabais notamment pour accepter le plan
de relance d'un rabais de leur
cotisation on va dire à l'union
européenne où c'est exactement ce qu'on
demande ils s'inquiètent à m'embrasser
dernière à dire qu'ils ont obtenus ça
c'était l'allemagne et l'autriche les
pays bas la suède et le danemark bat
pourquoi est-ce que la france ne
pourrait pas obtenir aussi un rabais de
sa cotisation à l'union européenne
puisque elle cotise beaucoup plus
qu'elle ne reçoit comme les autres et
également exactement pour les mêmes
raisons on va parler du pouvoir d'achat
puisque c'est évidemment la
préoccupation première des français
votre mesure phare c'est la baisse
la tva voire la suppression pour
certains produits vous promettez une
mesure immédiate mais juste comment elle
peut être immédiate alors pour faire ça
il faut passer par la loi et que le
parlement de la passagère avant fin juin
non mais on fera une loi de finances
bien entendu mais la baisse de la tva
sera proposé au parlement immédiatement
travailler pour les français avant au
mieux fin juillet bah écoutez en tous
les cas immédiatement ça peut aller très
vite effectivement il ya peut-être un
mois de décalage mais c'est la première
décision forte que nous allons prendre
la baisse de la tva à 5,5 c'est un choix
politique là encore tout n'est que choix
politique finalement politique c'est 9
milliards et demi la baisse de la tva
donc ce n'est pas neutre c'est un choix
que nous avons financé nous souhaitons
que ce soit pérenne parce que l'énergie
le chauffage les sens c'est sondés ce
sont des biens de nécessite nécessaires
à la vie des biens de première nécessité
et nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui il ya
trop de gens qui doit choisir entre se
chauffer et se nourrir donc nous voulons
quelque chose de pérenne nous voulons
absolument faire baisser les taxes sur
ces biens d'énergie 6 et pérenne ça
posera pas de problèmes avec l'union
européenne ou est-ce que vous allez
avoir des choses à dénoncer pas du tout
non pas du tout l'union européenne a
même incité d'ailleurs puisqu'il faut
demander la dire à l'union européenne
avant ou même après c'est un avis et
l'union européenne a même insisté ils
ont sorti un
jeu plus un texte une délibération à ce
sujet indiquant qu'en ce qui concernait
justement la baisse de la tva sur les
prix de première nécessité
il y était plutôt favorable l'autre
question c'est la question des retraites
grandes divergences l'atce avec emmanuel
macron alors vous vous dites c'est 60
ans pour les gens qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans et 62 ans au
delà est ce que privilégier l'âge
d'entrer sur le marché du travail et pas
les questions pénibilité c'est pas
injuste socialement c'est à dire ce que
vous reprochez aux manuels ma caméra
juste socialement mais oh on privilégie
exactement les questions de pénibilité
parce que comme en plus on commence tôt
plus souvent c'est parce qu'on fait un
travail qui est pénible et difficile
mais pas tout le temps sébastien chenu
pour un travail difficile et commencer à
le faire à 22 23 et bien sûr mais ça les
clauses de pénibilité elle existe tout
le temps est ce que je veux dire c'est
que quand vous avez commencé à
travailler tôt vous devez avoir la
possibilité de partir plus tôt 40
annuités 60 ans et après on vous l'avait
dit très justement le système devient
progressif moi ce que je ne comprends
pas dans ce que nous propose emmanuel
macron c'est que vous savez il ya 40%
des jambes qui lorsqu'ils partent en
retraite sont au chômage donc ça veut
dire que si vous poussez la retraite à
65 ans on va payer au chômage la société
va prendre en charge des gens qui sont
au chômage beaucoup plus longtemps donc
le court plus de ce que proposait la
nacre ont non seulement il est injuste
socialement mais il est fort coûteux
pour les finances publiques donc nous on
ne revient un système qui est celui que
vous avez annoncé 40 annuités 60 ans
avant 21 ans puis après progressif et
d'ailleurs dans la progressivité de ce
système vous gagnez encore aujourd'hui
des années par rapport au système actuel
mais avec quelle pension avec quel
montant de pension vont partir mais bien
que pas moins de 1000 euros c'est de
l'engagement de marine le pen pas de
pension en dessous de la loire a
toujours des des côtes mais on s'en va
tout
il n'y aura pas de possibilité de partir
avec une pension inférieure à 1000 euros
mais vous voyez avec une pension
complète exactement c'est exactement où
vous avez vos 40 annuités et vous savez
c'est là encore un choix de société en
fait lorsque emmanuel macron vous dis 65
ans vient vous expliquer que ça allait
en plus coûter très cher et c'est
antisocial et lorsque nous nous disons
40 annuités 60 ans avec 40 annuités
c'est un choix de société et comment on
le finance en finances marc plusieurs
clubs levier il faut activer évidemment
par l'emploi on est en train de nous
dire que le chômage a baissé
youpi on va pouvoir le faire donc si le
chômage continue de baisser si je la tue
vous aussi vous promettez le plein
emploi d'ici la fin du quinquennat bah
on promet le plein emploi on promet de
tout faire pour qu'il y ait
effectivement il y le plus grand nombre
d'emplois qu'ils soient pourvus par des
gens qui en cherchent c'est à dire
rendre raccorde les recherches et les
demandes je vous rappelle qu'à 130 mille
emplois qui sont tous pourvus
actuellement est un problème sur
l'apprentissage et la formation ça il
faut le faire la baisse de l'inégalité
entre les hommes et les femmes les
salaires hommes et femmes ça aussi ça
permet de faire entrer de la cotisation
et puis une politique de natalité qui
n'a pas été tenté encore dans notre pays
depuis fort longtemps souvent on en
parle c'est un peu une arlésienne on dit
en france où il faudrait relancer
beaucoup là la natalité on a des
dispositifs dans notre programme qui
permet de cette politique de natalité
parce que je pense que sur ce
financement des retraites il ya des
leviers à activer à court terme j'ai
intensité à moyen terme et à long terme
oui mais juste pour finir là le succès
avec aujourd'hui à beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent au delà de 62 ans parce
qu'ils veulent avoir des pensions plus
grande en quoi dans votre système ces
gens là ne serait plus obligé de
travailler au-delà de 60 parce qu'un
parti seulement vous avez 40 annuités
quel que soit le moment où vous êtes
sorti sur le marché du travail vous
pouvez partir en retraite donc c'est 40
annuités c'est ça la base du système
dominant termine par la campagne est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner quelques
indications sur la manière dont marine
le pen se prépare pour le grand débat
d'entre deux tours qui auront lieu
demain assez classiquement je pense
qu'en fait ça fait vivre naître beaucoup
de fantasmes ses préparations de débat
un solide emmanuel macron elle est
cachée dans une danse pas coupable non
tout ça est classique marine le pen se
prépare je crois que l
je note bien sûr la revanche elle 1017
france a très au sérieux mais je suis
persuadé que le président la république
se prépare la même façon en prenant les
choses au sérieux donc marine le pen est
lucide sur ce qui n'a pas marché et
l'idée c'est de quand quelque chose n'a
pas fonctionné ce n'est pas de refaire
la même erreur donc elle est très lucide
elle se prépare sérieusement qu'est ce
qui n'avait pas marché en 2017 jeu sera
pas je crois que la forme où il a
remporté sur le fond parce que lorsque
marine le pen par exemple a dit que le
même lac rond ce serait la brutalité les
français tous contre tous nous l'avons
vu en cinq ans c'est un quinquennat de
brutalité un créa quinquennat de mépris
des français mais je pense que ça avait
été effacée à travers une forme qui
effectivement était pas au niveau de ce
qu'on attendait d'un débat mme klein
c'est beaucoup plus préparés sur la
forme oui il y avait un axe stratégique
qui je crois avait été choisie qui
n'avait pas été le bon marine le pen
souhaitait démontrer montré qu'ils
étaient emmanuel macron le démasquer
alors qu'en fait on attendait d'elle
plutôt qu'elle montre qu' elle était
elle-même et ses propres arguments ne
fera que demain ça sera ça ça sera de
développer votre vision développer votre
réseau data exactement ce qu'on attend
d'un débat présidentiel deux visions de
la société de projet savoir en nous
emmène et comment nous y emmène avec
aussi quels types d'individus à la tête
de l'état comment les français vont être
considérée je pense que l'individu à la
tête de l'état vous donnera quelques
indications par exemple là dessus oui
mais c'est à dire c'est aussi le rapport
à la fonction au moins quand emmanuel
macron pose à moitié nue dans les
jardins de l'elysée je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ait tiré la fonction
présidentielle vers le haut je crois que
ça a choqué beaucoup de français
lorsqu'ils envoient les crs contre les
pompiers je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ait
pris soin du peuple français moi ce que
j'aimerais ça qu'on ait enfin une
présidente qui aime et qui respecte les
fronts elle donnera des éléments sur son
gouvernement en 2017
bah oui
merci mais regardez aujourd'hui au club
fera pas la même chose même si l'année
le maquereau négocie pas avec yannick
jadot j'imagine c'est pas le sujet du
débat que d'annoncer une liste de gens
auraient d'ailleurs les ministres des
bananes macron les a découverts après
qu'elle venait de ma françois lucas je
ne suis pas persuadé que le grand monde
connaissait blanc caire agnès buzyn
frédéric vidal et autres c'est au tour
de marine le pen ya des hommes et des
femmes certains sont un peu connu jean
paul garraud hervé juvin etc qui ont des
compétences techniques sur un certain
qu'elle a déjà dit que jean paul garraud
c'est à son garde des sceaux qu'avait
juin seraient semble tout
d'abord d'abord parce que je pense que
elle veut le préserver je pense qu'elle
veut aussi lui donner la possibilité
d'assumer pleinement sa fonction de
constituer un gouvernement et pas de
lancer une liste de noms un dernier mois
je vous ai mis des conditions à ce débat
des conditions non on s'est entendu le
président de la république et nous sur
des données techniques sur les
journalistes qui sont là comme ça se
fait traditionnellement peut-être que ça
pourrait évoluer d'ailleurs à l'avenir
ce genre de d'entente avant le débat
mais pas de conditions on a retravaillé
la liste des sujets qui sont soumises à
débat on l'a retravaillé avec
effectivement des équipes d'en face
aussi retravailler ça veut dire que vous
n'êtes pas venait pas suivi la liste de
d2 on a chacun fait je pense qu'une
modification mais d'ordre on a souhaité
faire entrer par exemple on a souhaité
que la thématique jeunesse et éducation
soit présente elle ne l'était pas chaque
animation sur l'entourage présents et
futurs de marine le pen vous avez un
certain nombre de cadres du
rassemblement national ils sont partis
chez eric zemmour pendant la campagne
est ce qu'ils sont en train de gratter à
la porte pour revenir est-ce que vous
l'y reprendrait ou pas quelques excuses
et décidé par on veut faire un
gouvernement d'union nationale donc pas
s'enfermer dans la tambouille
politicienne union nationale sans mes
amours east ainsi on a compris non je
crois que vous savez tout le monde est
bienvenu
je vous donne un exemple moi j'ai
accueilli avec beaucoup de bienveillance
le soutien des équipes d'eric zemmour et
cet après-midi voyez vous j'ai deux
rendez vous avec des députés qui
viennent de la majorité des modèles
matheron qui ont envie de discuter je
trouve que c'est intéressant de faire
comme ça car il ya des discussions
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont
été tellement déçu tellement horrifié
tellement scandalisée par la méthode et
par le peu de résultats du quinquennat
des manades mâcon qu'ils se disent que
le départ équivalent venir dans votre
gouvernement on n'en est pas là et c'est
pas moi qui vais mener ce genre de
négociation demande un nom quand même on
sait jamais non et c'est ce
que je dis c'est qu'on est des gens
ouverts on discute avec tout le monde ce
qu'on veut c'est redresser notre pays
merci sébastien chenu merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous regarde la une de
ouest france pouvoir d'achat ce que les
candidats proposent merci sébastien
chesnais alors si j'ai invité par parole
de marine le pen
[Musique]